come this way Enola homes 2 promises
more romance more action and more danger
than the original of course that means
bigger explosions awkward dancing and a
bunny in a baby stroller number one the
itsy bitsy Millie Bobby Brown went up
the water spout Millie was strapped in
with a wire for this scene it's one
thing to just do a stunt it's another
thing to also be in a dress doing this
stunt there's always a sense of
nervousness going up number two fist
fights and curly whirly bars make for
the ultimate romance these two couldn't
remember their lines if they hit them in
the face
Millie got her revenge if he's not a fan
of chocolate or toffee she just had a
curly worthy they're delicious go to
your local British candy store and get
one for yourself that's the tip
you should probably write that down
number three this is a scene we didn't
know we needed in our lives it was
chilly out the day they filmed the
breakout scene in Portsmouth and the
fire just wasn't lasting long enough to
keep any of the 30 extras warm by fire
we mean explosion
ready to go again
Style
I don't see it
number four Millie makes friends
wherever she goes or enemies we can't
tell sometimes she's such a troll look
at the way she smiles at the camera no
we're not talking about Enola smiling at
the camera this time Millie that's some
great casting right there I'm gonna have
to go and get Timothy chalamet to do the
same Millie is so in the habit of
looking at the camera for anola homes
she's worried she'll ruin takes on
Stranger Things number five our money's
on Millie he's spitting yes
even when these two are fighting it's
all Giggles on set we learn how to fight
how would you run out of life number six
Millie had to learn how to learn how to
dance that makes sense we think
Tewksbury had to teach Enola so Millie
can't get that good he's just looking at
plants being an idiot that's the reason
that we put him over there both actors
had to do a ton of dance lessons and I
think they all went out the window by
the time we went in there audio is a
pain you can't just talk and listen to
the music at the same time so the actors
were listening to the music on little
earbuds I was like keep the distance and
then the women producers on set were
like get it closer
closer number seven there's too much
nonsense going on on this set we've all
been there
it's really good guys
he's a mess maybe if you took that
bucket hat off you'd be able to see
better y'all see that bunny in the
stroller right that wasn't part of the
movie was it number eight you're gonna
want to play this one back with such
blurry video quality this looks pretty
impressive at one and a quarter speed go
ahead you know you want to YouTube won't
stop you number nine this movie was made
to look effortless and that takes a
whole lot of effort Millie Bobby Brown
helped conceptualize the costumes for
the movie while she's also a producer of
the film you know she had a huge
influence over the story the production
and yes even her costumes for the ball
gown scene she said I always knew I
wanted it to be a mint green dress
pistachio is a Nola's favorite color the
dress was tight when I say my lines I
always used to hold my breath and then
say them like with a lot of angst
there's no real corset under this dress
Millie was done with them and when it
came to the Matchstick girls she won
wanted them to look vibrant saying with
the misery that they were in and the
working environments they were in there
was still fire in them the color
palettes felt a bit more exciting
because the working environments do not
reflect who they were number 10.
wherever Milly goes she starts dance
parties it's common to see her dancing
on the set of stranger things too it's
nice to see she gets along with the
woman whose character threatened her
with a retractable knife sometimes you
just don't know
number 11 costumes lighting staging
cameras special effects it takes a
village the first big night scene when
Enola goes to follow May down the street
you will see
um a a gas lamp in the foreground and
Beyond
a Street full of mist and traffic and
people in different costumes and one
costume
maze stands out and she's lit perfectly
movies are a mishmash of different art
forms so it truly takes an army of
artists to make them work everything was
worked out and it was designed like a
painting it makes the art sing when the
other departments are in sync great
collaboration you know the theme of
collaboration is in the practice and the
execution as well as the story of the
film number 12. we miss you Sam but also
Enola homes 2 was great anyways that's
the sound of us sticking our tongue out
at you it wasn't intentional to exclude
Sam Claflin from the sequel
unfortunately scheduling conflict
stopped him from coming back but the
director said they were eager to work
with him again so who knows what the
future holds number 13 we love the
underlying symbol of the matches it only
takes one to start a fire so huge it
can't be put out the Matchstick Factory
in the movie uses the interior of an old
printing Factory in whapping it's not
very far from the Bryant and may Factory
the cause of the real magical strike in
1888 the production Designer Michael
Carlin said we also used videos from an
Indian match Factory where parts of the
process are still done by hand to
understand how the process actually
worked he also said that it was
important that all the Matchstick girls
knew what they were doing to the point
where it came naturally to them it's
quite a process in the 19th century the
matchsticks had to be manually dipped in
four different chemicals four chemicals
one of which was poisonous not for the
actors of course director Harry bradbeer
said I kind of dusted off my memory of
the match girls Factory strike I thought
well here's a story of Sisterhood here's
a story of going from a story that was
about constitutional change to Social
and Union change to Industrial action
number 14. we were wondering what looked
so strange head of hair and makeup with
the most amazing name Peter swords King
says we had to keep it very simple her
hair wouldn't be pounds that's much more
associated with someone much younger so
to have her hair down is going against
the rules of the day but that's very
much her character it's important to do
that with her rather than just fit what
everyone else does she comes from a
slightly eccentric background with her
mother when it comes to chase scenes
Peter sword's Kings said we wouldn't get
that movement that sort of intensity of
her emotions so in that sense her hair
being down although not correct for the
period is actually very useful for us
this is in contrast to the ball scene
everyone's hair is perfectly period
accurate and lovely but Enola will have
nothing to do with that because it's
unimportant to her it's important to put
a pin in it and keep it out of the way
maybe but that's it get your haircut
it's a mess number 15 recreating what's
already been perfected is an impossible
task it was a challenge to create
Sherlock's apartment because it's been
done so many times and done very well so
this team wanted to emphasize his love
for natural philosophy and music and
focused a bit on making him an obsessive
collector
maybe I can help you can help by leaving
isn't Enola homes 2 just as Charming
behind the scenes as it was on TV are
you looking forward to the third
installment what historically
significant moment do you think they
will latch on to next time let us know
in the comments and thanks for hanging
out with us here at the things
foreign